>> WHY IS THE WILL
ADMINISTRATION FLYING THOUSANDS
OF MIGRANTS FROM THE BORDER TO
NEW YORK IN THE MIDDLE OF THE
NIGHT.
>> I'M NOT SURE THE IT'S THE
MIDDLE OF THE NIGHT LET ME TELL
YOU WHAT IS HAPPENING HERE.
>> 2:30 A.M., 4:30 A.M. VERY
EARLY IN THE MORNING.
>> Will: CONFIRMATION.
THAT'S WHITE HOUSE CONFIRMING
THE "NEW YORK POST" REPORT THAT
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION HAS
BEEN SECRETLY FLYING UNDERAGED
MIGRANTS TO FLORIDA AND NEW YORK
IN THE MIDDLE OF THE NIGHT.
I HAPPEN TO THINK 2:00 AND 4:00
A.M. ALTHOUGH I OFTEN GET UP
4:00 A.M. "FOX & FRIENDS" IN THE
MIDDLE OF THE NIGHT.
FOR ALL THAT WE KNOW, IT MIGHT
NOT JUST BE LIMITED TO THOSE
STATES, BUSES THERE ARE WAITING
TO TAKE THEM TO PREARRANGED
DROPOFF LOCATIONS.
THERE IS NO END IN SIGHT TO THIS
SELF-CREATED BORDER CRISIS.
AS REPORTS ARE COMING IN THAT
THE, QUOTE:  MOTHER OF ALL
CARAVANS SELF-NAMED IS HEADING
TOWARDS BIDEN'S OPEN BORDER
JOINING ME IS NATIONALLY SAND NA
LOESCH AND MIRANDA DEVINE.
LANDING IN WEST CHESTER AND
OTHER PLACES AFTER BEING PICKED
UP AT THE SOUTHERN BORDER OF THE
UNITED STATES.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
WE JUST FOLLOWED THAT ROUTE FROM
TEXAS TO THE SOUTHERN BORDER TO
WHITE PLAINS AND THEY COME VIA
JACKSONVILLE, FLORIDA WHERE THEY
DROP OFF SOME OF THEIR MIGRANTS
AND THEN THEY ARRIVE IN THE DEAD
OF NIGHT AS YOU SAID.
AND THE CURFEW AT THAT WHITE
PLAINS AIRPORT IS MIDNIGHT THESE
PLANES ARE FLYING IN WAY AFTER
CURFEW.
CHARTER BUS AND POLICE ESCORT
WAITING FOR THEM.
WE JUST OBSERVED TWO FLIGHTS
WEST CHESTER AND ONE FROM WEST
CHESTER AND ONE THAT LEFT
JACKSONVILLE THAT CAME TO WHITE
PLAINS LAST WEEK.
OF THOSE WE SAW ABOUT 100
MIGRANTS COME OFF EACH PLANE AND
WE FOLLOWED A COUPLE OF BUSES
THAT WENT ONE TWO LONG ISLAND TO
DROP MIGRANTS OFF GROUP HOME
FORMER ORPHANAGE.
THEY HAVE CONTRACT WITH THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO HOUSE
MIGRANT YOUTH.
THERE WERE SEVERAL ADULTS THAT
AS FAR AS I COULD SEE AND
PHOTOGRAPHER COULD SEE THAT CAME
OFF THE FLIGHT AS WELL.
THE GOVERNMENT IS TELLING US ALL
CHILDREN IT DOESN'T LOOK LIKE
THAT TO US.
REGARDLESS, IT'S ALL BEING DONE
SECRETLY AND THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT WAS NOT TRYING TO
HIDE WHAT THEY WERE DOING.
THEY WOULD SHOW US WHO WAS ON
THE PLANE AND TELL US WHERE THEY
WERE TAKING THEM AND THEY
WOULDN'T BE DOING THESE FLIGHTS
IN THE DEAD OF NIGHT.
>> Will: IT SEEMS INDISPUTABLE
THAT THEY ARE DOING THIS
SECRETLY.
WHY ELSE BREAK CURFEW AND WHY
ELSE DO IT ALL THROUGH THE
NIGHT?
DANA, NOT TALKING ABOUT
NECESSARILY LARGE NUMBERS OF
PEOPLE BUT WHAT SEEMS TO BE
ESCAPING OUR POLICYMAKERS OR THE
PEOPLE WHO REFUSE TO MAKE POLICY
IS THE IDEA OF INCENTIVE.
IF IT IS THAT YOU CAN CROSS THE
BORDER AND IF YOU THEN GET
SHIPPED WHEREVER YOU WANT TO GO,
WHY WOULD YOU BE SURPRISED THEN
THAT A CARAVAN OF 95,000 PEOPLE
SET TO LAUNCH IN MEXICO IN THE
NEXT COUPLE OF DAYS?
THEY ARE CALLING IT BY THE WAY.
THE MADRE OF CAR VANA, THE
MOTHER OF ALL CARAVANS.
>> EXACTLY RIGHT, WILL.
IT IS INCENTIVE.
WHEN PEOPLE SEE THAT THERE IS NO
LAW AND ORDER BEING ENFORCED NOT
JUST AT THE BORDER BUT IN THE
INTERIOR.
I THOUGHT MIRANDA'S STORY WAS
FANTASTIC.
MY QUESTION AS A PARENT WAS
WHERE ARE THE PARENTS OF THESE
CHILDREN, THESE MINORS BEING
TRANSPORTED UP TO NEW YORK AND
BEING PUT ON BUSES THEREAFTER.
DO WE EVEN KNOW WHERE THEY ARE
GOING?
HAVE ANY LOCAL OFFICIALS BEEN
MADE AWARE?
THAT'S A VERY SERIOUS ISSUE.
BUT, WILL, FURTHER TO YOUR
POINT, WITH THE BORDER, YOU ARE
GOING TO HAVE MORE CHILDREN THAT
ARE GOING TO BE COMING UP
TOWARDS THE BORDER AND TAKEN BY
COYOTES AND TAKEN ACROSS THE
BORDER OR TRAFFICKED.
THAT'S THE OTHER THING.
WE DON'T EVEN KNOW ABOUT THE
SAFETY OR WELL-BEING OF THESE
KIDS AND THIS IS SUPPOSED TO BE
IN THE NAME OF SOME KIND OF FAKE
COMPASSION FROM THIS
ADMINISTRATION ABOUT THE POLITE
OF THESE PEOPLE THAT ARE TRYING
TO SEEK ENTRY INTO THE UNITED
STATES IN IF IT'S ABOUT
COMPASSION, THERE WOULD BE SOME
SORT OF REGULAR ORDER THAT
PEOPLE COULD FOLLOW AND WE COULD
VERIFY TO SEE WHO THEY WERE AND
MAKE SURE THAT, YES, THEY ARE A
FAMILY UNIT AND THESE CHILDREN
ARE THEIR CHILDREN AND MAYBE YOU
COULD STAY AND APPLY FOR ASYLUM
AND FOLLOW THE PROCESS LIKE
EVERY OTHER PERSON, WILL, THAT'S
EVER HAD TO IMMIGRATE TO THIS
COUNTRY.
AND THAT'S A COMPLETE BREAKDOWN
OF COURSE HAVE THIS INCENTIVE WE
WILL HAVE THIS AGAIN AND AGAIN
AND AGAIN AND THIS
ADMINISTRATION WILL FIX IT.
>> Will: WHAT ARE THOSE DETAILS,
DANA, WHERE ARE THEY GOING?
WHY ARE A LONE CAN YOU AS A
MIGRANT SAY I WOULD LIKE TO BE
DROPPED OFF IN NEW YORK AND YOU
HAVE A PRIVATE CHARTERED FLIGHT
DO SO?
YOU SAY MY PARENTS ARE IN NEW
YORK AND, THEREFORE, YOU ARE PUT
ON A PLANE?
DETAILS OF HOW THIS COMES
TOGETHER LOGISTICALLY ARE
MYSTIFYING.
>> YOU HAVE TO LOOK AT THE
PUBLICLY AVAILABLE FLIGHT LOGS
TO SEE IT HAPPENING ALL OVER THE
COUNTRY.
SEVERAL HUBS ACROSS THE COUNTRY,
THESE PLANES BECAUSE YOU ARE NOT
GOING TO LEAVE UPWARDS OF
1.5 MILLION ILLEGAL MIGRANTS
COUNSEL BY THE BORDER BECAUSE IT
WOULD BE A CATASTROPHE.
THEY HAVE TO DISPERSE THEM
QUIETLY AROUND THE COUNTRY AND
COMMUNITIES THAT DON'T KNOW
WHAT'S GOING ON.
AND WE HAVE SEEN AS WE WATCHED
ONE BUS TAKE A -- OR TWO BUSES
ACTUALLY ONE FLIGHT TAKE A BUNCH
OF THESE MIGRANTS ON WEDNESDAY
NIGHT TO AND DROP THEM OFF AT A
REST AREA OFF THE NEW JERSEY
TURNPIKE.
NOW, IF THEY WERE CHILDREN, THIS
WAS REALLY FAILURE OF THE DUTY
OF CARE OF HHS BECAUSE THEY
DIDN'T CHECK THE IDENTIFICATION
OF ANY OF THE PEOPLE THAT CAME
UP IN CARS TO PICK THOSE PEOPLE
UP.
HOW DO WE KNOW WHO THEY ARE?
>> Will: OH, WOW.
>> WE KNOW TOM HOMAN WHO WAS
BORDER SECURITY UNDER DONALD
TRUMP SAID THAT THEY SPENT
INORDINATE AMOUNT OF TIME
VETTING THE PEOPLE THAT COULD
COME UP AND PICK UP
UNACCOMPANIED MINORS, BUT THAT'S
BEEN SHORT CHANGED WITH THIS
GOVERNMENT.
AND THEY ARE NOT TALKING.
>> Will: REALLY QUICKLY, NO
QUESTION IT CHANGES THE FABRIC
OF AMERICA IS IT INTENDED TO DO
SO.
>> WE NEED PEOPLE TO COME IN
LEGALLY NOT ILLEGALLY.
YOUR FIRST ACT IN THE COUNTRY
DOESN'T BREAK THE LAW.
IT IS MELLING POT.
THAT ISN'T THE P.C. WORD TO